now you tell me if you're not using
strength
you see your ego's being pricked because
you're
it's gotta work
so you're all using strength
so when
um cytosense the
was grabbed by me and he staggered
a lot of you have heard this before
he went like that and he said this is
the strongest man on this tatami
i wasn't doing it but i was yeah
i'm from england
and then he goes
and i'm as big as a house at this point
and then he goes if he doesn't learn to
lose his strength he will never find her
since his aikido
you know
it took me
almost 20 years i know a lot of people
want it in that army it took me almost
20 years to understand that
because
i'm thinking i'm not using strength but
look at the size of me
how can i not use strength
so what i done was i found kaitenaghi
worked but paul
he said to me your kitten egg is wrong
you should be
here on the back of the head
and i said but if i do that
if i do that
i could use strength
he said yeah but what you're doing honey
is wrong and i said no what i'm doing
it's got to be right because if i'm not
using strings
if i'm not using strength and i'd say
stand up
then it must be it must be closer to our
senses like you know
then
what
so those of you are struggling let's
have a look
who's who's who's struggling everybody
yeah let me have a let me have a pair
that any pair
i'll get to you know it doesn't matter
what cut there's not that many kitten
naggies but let's say you know any
kitten you up here
so
paul's hand is down
so he's that's right so paul has already
his third leg down
so it's going to be difficult
but john put in there
what you need to do is it it needs to be
do it again it needs to be so dan
doesn't quite go there
so he
so paul
right
he doesn't want to feel off balance
you know when they say you've got a 10
in aikido 99 is a timmy
it's not the fist
it's
paul thinking
i might be here
you know like china hanker
i'm happy here
it's taken their mind because you've
left them thinking what are you doing
nothing to me
so you need him to be in the kaitenagi
so that he paul thinks
what am i waiting for then
but if he tries to come up
he goes
i didn't know i was going to knock out a
camera
so the art is getting
the art that i'm looking for
is to get him
so that paul thinks that he's
comfortable
let's turn up
good there you go again
so what i've done last time was i just
done here
and here
and then i put the two angles together
so this one's going to my fingers this
one
is not going into his body it's going to
this hand i go like that
i lock the two and now i lock it
mentally yeah
see that feel the difference
but i mentally have to leave them
if i don't link them mentally then it's
mechanically linked
a lot of people think oh it's a load of
old
rubbish you know all this spiritual
stuff but it's it's if i go
pin him here then his hands down he can
stop me pushing me
he can also come up
yeah
so you want to get your partner
at the point they think that they're
fine
and then you ask them can you come up
and then if you struggle then obviously
you haven't got all the pieces together
what
your partner wants to do is when he
starts to try to come up
if i'm pushing more on the upper arm but
what you'll find is you're more likely
to be pushing more on the head i don't
know if you are or not but nine out of
ten times you actually start pushing
more on the head because you've already
pushed on the arm without perhaps
knowing it
when the when you can get the same
so he now thinks
so is there a is there one stronger than
the other no no
all right
so he
so you perhaps got have a better
conversation with your partner and
saying is one more than the other and
nine times out of ten he's going to
come up
where's the pressure more
on the head yeah all right
so so get some feedback you know it's
if you take this i want everybody to
take this away today to go
[Music]
yeah but all techniques ain't going to
work like that are they then you're
thinking wrong
of course they're not going to work all
like that but what i'm doing is i'm
giving you
the golden ticket that i've had for
years
to the doorway like i'm saying here's
the key you just got to find what door
it fits
i need you to have the seed
to be able to do it
quickly and fastly and come up
i want
because we become we're a lot more
sensitive than we actually know
ourselves there's a lot more going on in
here
i remember going to the doctors and
saying
you have to give me something for stress
and i said about you know i don't want
to be on for long
he said it didn't come in a hurry and
it's not going to go in at home
and i just always remember them words
and it's the same as this it's not gonna
you know you might find it today
but it's not going to
stay with you because how many times
you're going to do kaitenagi you know
i'm going to do some next month in the
class because i like it
but once you do that you'll start
realizing that you can't do you can't do
show manucci hosts like this even if
you're on a seminar and the teacher's
doing them do them because you have to
do what the teacher's doing
but
so you start simplifying your own aikido
and that's at the end of the day that's
what matters that's why we're here i'm
not here for mark am i i'm not there for
nick i'm here for me and without you i
can't keep training so i'm like i've got
to keep you all happy
but i want you to go
i've seen something today i've tasted
something today that i never felt before
wow i want that the same as i talked
about the mona lisa tripod i want that
and it doesn't matter whether you're a
fifth band or
you know or a fifth cue
it's the thing
to do is to realize we use too much
strength
you should about do it fast or slow he
should feel no
you should feel nothing except for when
he tries to come up
and that's what um
oh sensei said they should
lock their self really
you know that's
we know aikido is if somebody asks you
about aikido what'd you say
oh that's like and then they repeat yeah
i've heard that one that's the one where
you they use the other person's
strength isn't it
and you go yeah that's the one
so so yeah
so we're actually the culprits aren't we
we're the enemy
okay that's um
let's do a few more minutes